100 m lancer de poids saut à la perche
dimanche dernier les licenciés
d'athlétisme de saint quentin de 7 à 11
ans avaient rendez-vous à maurepas pour
une compétition un peu particulière le
dk poussins comprenez le décathlon
adapté aux plus jeunes augustin fait de
l'athlétisme depuis deux ans et il a
encore du mal à choisir son activité
préférée j'aime bien le sens longueur
qu'encourt le son des fins j'aime tout
ce retard était plutôt pas mauvais aussi
pas gagné là bas oui il veut aussi c'est
parce que je suis gros donc serré choix
avantagé
pour son père ce type de rencontre c'est
avant tout une scène émulsion des
petites compétitions qui anime peu la
flamme oscille envie de continuer voilà
ddca poussins des petites courses la
semaine des as et el hadi en course
objectif pour les organisateurs donné le
goût de l'athlétisme dès le plus jeune
âge chaque épreuve du décathlon est donc
adapté à la taille et à la force des
sportifs en herbe sont les atouts du
site le rapproche de ce que font les
grands alors l'ascétisme et en version
simplifiée mario porteix ces nouveaux du
javelot trouve que c'est importé xing
espèce de boule elle conclu oui à vous
reposer le mouvement mais plus
simplement fait pour éviter qu'ils se
blessent c'est la première compétition
en extérieur de l'année pour ses
poussins si la fin de la rencontre s'est
terminée avec un véritable podium et un
classement les 75 compétiteurs sont tout
de même repartis chacun avec une
médaille